ABOUT FBER OTHERDATHE OPERES A A
THERE ARDOCUMENTS.
>> FBI OPERATIVES E N THE L .
ITMONDAY
HOW ON
HEYU EATE
EVERYBODY HAS AROINT.  HIS WORK
GOPARROT
EO.AUSE OPEOP-RAT
DOMINO A
DID. HE IS IEST TUCKER
SOURCES? AR EXECUTIVESRS AND
DID ANYONE VET TREPORTING?
DID THE FOX WSO THING?N'N
WHE EWY Y.T X H RICOGHT NOW??CAO
CARLN ND ISLANUT OS
CLAIMING TO BENGHEIS VIEWERS.
AND THE DEFENSE  FOXS THAT
SM, HIS FANS T'SYONE KNOWST'ONB
THEY TRUST TKEN AL
WHFO?
INTO H CLAIM
LOOOMINLET  MY E-MAE
THERE'S BEEN -- , SPONSE FM
C QUT BASIWS
WHERS?ING.
WITHW IS DAVID ZERWICK
A  SUN."D AUTHORF UE
I KNOW TO
NG MY  SEE IGET
TO MY TIONS.N'RO
CK THE STORIES FOR
YEAR
OBVISL DAVIDONEPY
FOX DOESN'T COMM IS HIS OWN GUY
HE DOE HE WAS.
>>I THINK TH
AID THAT FOX KED AN
OPLE ACSAY, OH, THOSE
OPINION BROOKE
BLAIR, BLAH, BLAH. IPROPAGANDA
POLITICAL ERATION, ENTERPRISE,
WAS SMART ENOU T AS
IF IT WAS MAINSTREAM,
JOURNALISTIC NEWSCELNN, BUE
RIGHT.
N LEANIHT
PROSTATING OITEES BEFORE
DONA
FOD M TOP TO
BOTTOMTHEY WILL NEVER INVESTIGA
ANAED
YOA
JOURLIEROV WHE L NNING ITLAN MU,
OPW P,IO FULL-FELONY
K ABT  E
DIO.
YOU HAVE FOX NAT O
GO ON THE NEWS IS THE .ANT
WHEN YOU HAV
MILLION LIKE HE  YOU
SAX NEWS TAKESA MAINSTREAMD OF
OPLE ORIT.THATGEROUSS E
OF IT AND WHATR IS
TUALLY
IACH YOU
YOOUT
PROPAGANDA.
WH?
IS HE CREA FIGHT AND
DOING?S THAT
>> HE , RHETORIC SCHOLARS KWN E
WHEN YOU TAP INTO  EMOTIONS, YO
'SOULOGY., AN
REON
ISOMETHING
DANG ITHE  BODY' FLOODS  TISOL.
THOSE TAKE OVE BRAIN S FIRSTE
ABCALLY.YOCLEXM AND THENSPIRACYF
DOHAVE YOUR REHEYSSPY THEORY AND
HE'SNARRATIVEST PEOPLE WILL LIE.
HOW IS THAT  THEORY?JOB.HAT BA
HI ABOUT TIR WHEN YOU
RUN OVER A N INSTEAD O
NGLAT,
AGY DN'T  S, YOU ARE THTRH AND
WON'T U EVEN LET U
THIS OATE? YFACTS,SAY REG THE H
US, RIGHT? LF CONSPIRAEO BE
PUNCREE CONSTHRY, TH YOU MAKE.
>> SO HOOUT OF THI, JENNIF SS P
ATTENTION  T MEDIA YOU UML LIKEE
OUS WHEN'R THE
HAT SIED
ANXIOUS, ANTHAT PROBLEM.INK ITT
KIND OF  MORE E  WATCH TH
EMPATHETIC T ANDLIZE
URAL RESPONSE.
THEY'REE EIH
CONSTANTLY IN THIS STATIGHT O.
I JUST CHECKEDY E-MA
YET.
D E OF T TV
G FOLA
WEEK
ID ON FOX.ING FOR PUTIN.
MEI WAS ACTUALLYURPRISED, EVEN
BRIAN.X, I WAS
T,
SAY -- CAE CTION.
OWG TO S B BBARRASSMENT BEUS WTT